[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster but the Prime
Minister has been a stride the global
stage this week he's heading home from
the G20 in Bali now but as he leaves the
sunny skies behind there's no shortage
of dark clouds to welcome him home
Dominic Robb was standing in for his
boss at pmqs today after calling for an
inquiry into bullying allegations about
himself and we're just hours away from a
budget in orbit name that could Define
Rishi sunx Premiership and the fate of
his party too we will bring you takes
from all sides over the next 60 minutes
now after days of dodging and denial
this morning the Deputy Prime Minister
finally acknowledged formal complaints
about his misconduct but his letter
contains no hint of admission or apology
it was the Battle of the deputies at PM
Keys today that was Angela Rayna
attacking her opposite number over
allegations of bullion
I received notification this morning I
immediately asked the Prime Minister set
up an independent inquiry into them I'm
confident I'd be professionally
throughout but of course I will engage
thoroughly
well everything in the Commerce today
though was really just a Prelude to the
main event tomorrow when Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor will unveil a very
significant budget in all by name we're
going to be asking our viewers what
they're hoping for or perhaps dreading
from that uh Autumn statement there they
are looking forward to speaking to them
getting their takes uh later we'll also
have some top guests on the program
today including work and pensions
secretary Mel stride what could be
happening to his budget Labor's Shadow
education secretary Bridget Phillipson
will be on the program plus the former
Chancellor and conservative Grandy Lord
Ken Clark we'll also be speaking to the
former National Security adviser Lord
Peter Ricketts plus watch more besides
on the take
foreign
[Music]
good evening well there's usually
nothing a prominenter likes more than
getting out of the country and looking
statesman-like at the big Global Summits
and Richard cynic had plenty of that at
the G20 this week and of course Global
relations were given a fresh urgency
today thanks to a stray missile hitting
Poland but the PM is likely to be back
to the UK with a bump as the decisions
in tomorrow's Autumn statement will
likely dominate for days weeks even
years to come so let's crack straight on
we're going to start with the best bits
of the week so far the Home Secretary
has now signed a long-awaited deal with
France this morning and at tackling the
growing migrant crisis I've been
absolutely clear that illegal migration
particularly in the numbers that we've
been seeing more recently is totally
unacceptable I'm confident that we can
get the numbers down but I also want to
be honest with people that it isn't a
single thing that will magically solve
this we can't do it overnight the
leaders of the world's biggest economies
Gather in Bali this morning for the G20
meeting with Russia's foreign minister
sitting there we highlighted both the
illegality and barbaric nature of
Russia's War coroner has ruled that a
two-year-old boy died as a result of a
severe respiratory condition caused by
prolonged exposure to mold in his home
people in homes you know and fit human
habitation and all this what a battery
all this oh if only we had more
government money do your job man NATO is
facing its biggest decision of the
Ukraine war tonight after what appeared
to be Russian missiles hit a village in
Poland killing two people we have no
indication that this was the result of a
deliberate attack Dominic Robb the
Deputy Prime Minister says he's
confident he behaved professionally
after two formal complaints were made
about his conduct this morning the
Deputy Prime Minister finally
acknowledged formal complaints about his
misconduct this is an see bullying week
will he apologize I immediately asked
the Prime Minister set up an independent
inquiry into them I'm confident I pay
professionally throughout
well lots of things to focus on today on
the program but it's right to start I
think with tomorrow's Autumn statement
we know there will be both tax Rises and
spending cuts and a little early today I
spoke to one person who is perhaps
closer to what's going to happen the
most the work and pension secretary
former chair of the treasury select
committee and key Ally of Rishi sunak as
well now stride
thank you very much for being on the
program now there's been an awful lot of
pitch rolling about what to expect for
from the Autumn statements um by
watering difficult decisions according
to the chancellor do we need to brace
ourselves I think it's going to be quite
tough because what we do know very
clearly is we've got very high inflation
very tight labor market we're going to
be uh have the prospect of pretty low
growth for some time in common with
other economies around the world the IMF
is saying about a third of world
economies or going to recession in the
next year and that's the backdrop with
this huge fiscal hole that needs to be
filled so what we know from that is
they're going to be some very tough
decisions he's going to have to take on
tax and on spending what we don't know
is what exactly they're going to look
like but there is a 50-plus billion
pound fiscal hold to fill and that means
some big decisions I think oh we were
going to be paying more tax the chance I
think has said that
um whether it's absolutely everybody
down to every last member of the public
that pays more tax or not let's wait to
see but I think the point that he's
making there is that the size of that
fiscal hole is such that you're going to
probably have to look at tax measures
that are fairly broadly based if you're
going to bring in the amounts of money
that's required and the course talk
about cuts to public services and that's
going to be alarming for a lot of people
who will be looking at the state of
their Public Services thinking where is
the fat to be trimmed here schools for
example you know where they got you know
talking about cutting teaching
assistants or cutting back on textbooks
at a time when inflation is already at
11 yes
that's part of what's going to be really
difficult now one of the first decisions
he's going to have to take is what's the
balance between tax Rises and
expenditure cut so we don't know that
yet but the more he leans into tax of
course the less he'll have to lean into
controlling expenditure well you're
absolutely right with inflation as it is
at the moment given that most spending
settlements uh were struck some time ago
when expectations of inflation were much
lower there are going to be those
additional pressures on the public
finances but let's see what he has to
say about that bear in mind of course
the pain here will probably be spread
over several years maybe five years
before we reach the critical point where
his fiscal Target kicks in which I think
will probably be 20 27 28 and it's in
that year that he has to get all his
sons to add up it doesn't necessarily
have to go for lots of short-term pain
you could spread it you see I this is
where my slight skepticism kicks in I'll
be honest
uh because obviously there will be some
things that come in earlier
it's cuts cuts and spending squeezes a
bit of a fantasy designed to reassure
the markets in the short term but in the
long term particularly the ones that as
you say are post the next election it's
not going to happen on it well I think
the critical phrase you've just used
there Sophie is reassure the markets
that's the litmus test so the markets
will have a very good news for this they
will look at the plans that are put
forward and they will say perhaps I
don't think it will happen but maybe
they might say there's too much pain
tomorrow you know it's getting too
easier ride he's pushing it all to the
back beyond the next general election it
doesn't feel credible I don't think
you'll make that mistake so I think
there will be a fairly balanced budget
in terms of what tax and spending are
doing the short and medium term as well
as as well as further down the line and
I want to talk to you a bit about your
department work and pensions at Big
spending Department of course now Jamie
hunt told me at the weekend we've got a
big increase in the number of people who
aren't working who aren't taking part in
work even though they perhaps could is
he right yes he's absolutely right now
as it happens compared to other major
economies they are in a very similar
position in fact we're in no worse
position than most other economies but
nonetheless there are nine million
people who are economically inactive and
they fall into four basic groups one is
students then you've got those that have
retired early you've got those that are
long-term uh sick and you've got those
that are caring have caring
responsibilities now each one of those
cohorts has different levers if you like
that you can try and pull to encourage
and support them into work and what the
Prime Minister has asked me to do is to
look at that as a main project now for
the DWP is how do we really get across
all those cohorts and do whatever we can
to make sure we increase the uptake of
those going into the workplace
particularly as that number's grown a
lot during the pandemic and it's just
600
000 went into economic inactivity over
the period of so what levers are you
going to pull then to try and encourage
if you like so these people yeah so the
kindest gloss on it yes so it depends on
the group that you're looking at so for
example if they are already engaged with
the department for work and pensions
they're on benefits one would look at
for example what kind of support are we
providing people to get into work how
frequently frequent is the contact we
have for those for example that are on
Universal Credit uh how many hours do we
expect people to work before we take a
lighter touch approach to that you know
do we do we extend the number of hours
we expect people to be in work before we
say right okay we can leave you uh that
support withdraw that support a little
bit so I think there are issues around
conditionality and benefits if you've
retired however early say age 55 and
you're feeling comfortable and you're
not claiming any benefits at all then
you're kind of beyond our boundary but
nonetheless there might be things that
government more generally can do to
encourage those people back into work
flexible working offers for example
making sure all that those individuals
are really clear as to what the costs of
their retirements are going to be
because they're working on this
assumption that you know taking it easy
at 55 is going to still work out by the
time you reach 65. so so there are all
sorts of different interventions but
what I'm going to do is look at each one
of those cohorts in detail and do the
really hard research kicking of the ties
to make sure we come up with the best
possible policy so you're quite open
saying that you are going to be trying
to effectively push some people on
benefits back into work they should be
working more when the when the Prime
Minister appointed me in the cabinet
room he discussed the various things he
wanted me to do on top of that list was
economic uh uh you know those that are
disengage I mean some will be saying
that it sounds you know could be seen as
a bit heartless if you know a lot of
people about particularly on you know
long-term sake or on or on caring as you
say or on benefits struggling and trying
to make things work with inflation
they'll be looking at what you're saying
thinking hang on a minute he's talking
about taking my money away from me and I
can't well well this is well I'm not
talking about taking people's money away
and certainly not for very good reason
and I mean if people don't engage and
expect to be supported and not do
anything to look for work then that's a
particular scenario but most people are
far from that particular situation but I
think it is true that there are some
within those various groups that we can
help if we come up with the the right
policies to do that and that's what I
think we should do and we know that of
that 9 million 1.7 million are saying
that they want to work
so not everybody there was some
long-term people with long-term
illnesses where it just won't be
appropriate and it won't work and I
accept that but there are millions there
are some Millions for whom work is
actually going to be quite appealing if
we just make it happen
uh now the it it looks from reporting so
the pensions triple lock may be
protected you know the government's
talked a lot about people with the
broader shoulders bearing at some of the
burden uh we're expecting to see a
squeeze in pay if you like for public
sector workers
um is it fair that for a retiree many of
whom are wealthy although except of
course there is pension poverty that
they might see their pensions go up by
10 along with inflation when public
sector workers could only dream of that
kind of price okay well the first thing
is I I can't confirm or deny whether the
triple lock will stay unfortunately I
have to wait until tomorrow what the
chancellor has to say but in terms of
that 10 of course the up rating that
occurred last time around which was in
April of uh last year uh pegged on the
previous September's inflation rate was
just 3.1 so there's an inflation was
running higher over most of the period
after that so there's an element of
swings and round events but I think the
critical thing about pensioners is that
unlike most of the rest of us there is a
time of life where re-engaging with
Workforce is much more problematic and
difficult and therefore it's much harder
for them to adjust their own economic
situation a public sector
as well if someone click their fingers
and get a pay rise indeed indeed so that
that's why um the government has come
forward with all these interventions
like for example my department has been
sending eight million households 60 650
pounds now they are households typically
on UC uh they're the lowest income
households in the country and then
there's 150 pounds for those with
disabilities 300 pounds for uh
pensioners again
um and uh help with council tax for
those on the lower council tax ban so
there's lots of targeted support that's
going into looking after just the people
that you're referring to okay um I want
to talk to you about Dominic Robb he of
course is in facing an investigation
into allegations of bullying Behavior
is it correct that Richie sunac will be
the ultimate Arbiter of that
investigation and all the findings will
be passed to him to make a judgment my
understanding and I think Dominic has
done exactly the right thing there have
been a couple instances of complaints
that have come forward he's gone to the
Prime Minister he's recommended to the
Prime Minister that he looks into this
the pm has agreed when Lord guide is
replaced then there will be somebody to
look into that and I have no doubt that
that individual whoever it is will do so
without fear and favor so it won't be
ethics advisor sacked by Boris Johnson
well quite useful to have around the the
prime well the Prime Minister has made
it very clear the the that integrity and
transparency and good governance is
absolutely core to this government's
Mission so I have no doubt whoever
replaces Lord guide conducts this
investigation will do so without fear
favor or indeed interference so I'm
absolutely confident it will be
confident that it will be an independent
uh exercise and just finally I want to
talk a little bit about the wider
culture in Westminster so you can park
the allegations about Dominic Robb for
now and you know our reporters Liz Bates
and Aggie Schoenberg have been
investigating a bullying in Westminster
for a podcast or Open Secret all parties
not just the conservatives and I just
want to read to you some of the
anonymous quotes given to them
she was always asking me the MP from the
staffer she was always asking me to do
things that were inappropriate she got
me to scrub stains out the carpet
another one I remember feeling like a
dog in an rspca advert where they hide
behind the sofa when the owners are
coming back and finally I knew she had a
terrible reputation some other MPS
approached me after I left and said oh
my God how did you last that long right
well clearly we don't know the specifics
of all those cases that you've raised
but they sound pretty horrific and
they're unacceptable and that's why I
think the House of Commons as an in
general sort of umbrella to all the MPS
as employers has come a long way
actually with its grievance procedures
and people are encouraged to come
forward now so I think that's the way
forward but it's very sad when you hear
those things I totally agree I can only
speak from my own experience mixing and
mingling with members of parliament okay
I don't spend a lot of time down in the
bars as it happens and perhaps that's
where all the bad behavior goes on but I
found generally speaking that colleagues
are serious people who want to do the
best other constituency and I say that
right across the house all parties and
generally treat their staff with great
respect but where there are exceptions
it needs to be dealt with and I think
the processes are now there for that to
happen Okay thank you very much thank
you
well that was a working pension
secretary at Mel stride perhaps giving
us a bit of a flavor on what to expect
from his department at least tomorrow
well let's turn to labor now shall we
and the party Shadow education secretary
Bridget Phillipson
big day tomorrow Autumn statement what
are you going to be looking out for
the key for us is to look at whether the
government are making Fair choices where
it comes to taxation in particular so
we'll be doing things differently
whether it's ending that non-dome tax
status charging v80 on private schools
putting that money into State education
there's a lot of areas really that the
government have got some straightforward
choices I think around fairness but also
on growth you know we've had terrible
growth these last 12 years as a country
obviously we're facing particularly
acute pressures at the moment on the
cost of living because the conservatives
crashed the economy and the fact we're
having tomorrow is as a result of that
failure but this isn't just a more
recent problem we've had a terrible
record as a country on growth and
Labor's green Prosperity plan is about
delivering that growth with high paid
you know what good jobs secure jobs in
every corner of our country you say that
it's because the conservatives crash the
economy it's a bit more complicated than
that though isn't it obviously not you
know completely negating the impact of
the mini budget but we are housing a
global inflation crisis we're seeing a
war in Ukraine we're seeing what
happened with Putin as well they crash
the economy and they've mismanaged it
for 12 years so if you've been in charge
of 12 years you've had a long time to
make choices about the direction of our
country I mean undeniably there are
Global factors of course every country
is confronted with some of this but
doesn't explain why we're bottom of the
pile where it comes to growth we are
we're uniquely exposed as a country
going into this crisis the fact that we
are so dependent our energy security you
know we don't have that independence of
supply and part of Labor's plan is about
making sure that in future we're not so
exposed to those kinds of global
fluctuations but this is squarely on
them the fact that people are going to
be paying more on their mortgages every
month is because of the decisions of the
conservative party and Jeremy Hunt's
been pretty upfront that there is going
to be a public spending squeeze as well
there's been strong hints that the NHS
is going to be protected that the
pensions triple lock is going to be
protected that benefits will be rising
in line with inflation
are you a bit worried about what that
means for education in your department
I'm incredibly worried about the
pressure that our schools are under at
the moment and when I speak to heads
when I speak to teachers and support
staff they are doing amazing work
working so hard but the challenges and
the pressure you know they see it every
day with children arriving at school who
haven't had that good start that they
need where their families are struggling
to give them the best that's why labor
would deliver breakfast clubs for every
Primary School child so they get a good
start to the day but the pressures that
schools are under having to make
decisions about whether they're going to
have to lose staff or whether they can
afford to give children the basics I
think one really straightforward way
that the government could fill some of
that would be to end the tax benefits
that private schools enjoy and how much
more into that race though that raises
1.7 billion it's not going to really
touch the scientists that I think it
would make a big difference you look at
the number of teachers that you could
recruit six and a half thousand new
teachers better mental health support in
our schools careers guidance for all of
our children it gets you a lot and I
don't think you can go around seeing
that you've got choices to make and not
the really straightforward easy choices
there is no justification for that kind
of taxpayer subsidy of private schools
and it's the opportunity for the
chancellor on Thursday to end that and
to put that money into the schools that
support the vast majority of our
children you've talked about the
pressures that we're under whether it's
inflation but also of course borrowing
and borrowing costs
um are there any areas of public
spending where you think actually yes
this is where we could look at findings
and savings
I think it's quite tough I mean there
has been a big squeeze over the last 12
years I mean we do believe that you need
to make sure you're getting value for
money that's why we've said that labor
would set up the office of value for
money to make sure that we're getting
real value from everything any areas
where you think that look maybe this if
we have to make difficult choices this
is the department where maybe they could
fall
um there will you know no government is
perfect in how it spends its money and
of course you should be looking at
getting the best out of the money that
you're spending but I don't think if I
look for example across education it's
not that they are Awash with money and
have got more money than they know what
to do with I mean unlike the oil and gas
companies who haven't actually been
taxed for what they have been enjoying
at the moment so I think all of this
comes down to choices for government
both in terms of priorities but also tax
fairness you can't just that is the key
though isn't it the choices for
government which I guess is why I'm
asking you know if there is any areas
where you think savings could be found
well I'd always be up to looking for it
but
I think given the pressures that our
public sector has been under these last
12 years whether it's our schools or
hospitals an awful lot has been cut back
and cut back to such a point that for
example with Schools they're the last
line of defense really for so many of
our communities that wider
infrastructure that wider support that
families need that's gone and so much of
it falls to school so actually if you to
free up if you get high standards and
excellence in all of our schools you
could deliver that far more effectively
if you had that wider support available
to All Families so that doesn't always
just fall to our teachers and school
leaders and I want to ask you about
Dominic Robb who obviously is facing
allegations of bullying and there's
going to be in independent investigation
into his conduct he says he welcomes it
he'll comply are you satisfied with that
well we don't know who as yet is to lead
this independent inquiry of course the
Prime Minister hasn't appointed his
independent ethics advisor he promised
us a government that would be rooted in
Integrity professionalism and
accountability this Falls a long way
short but it's not just about about
Dominic Robb you look at sowella
bravaman back in the cabinet having
breached the ministerial court on an
issue of National Security Gavin
Williamson put back into government I
think this speaks to a deeper question
as to Richie see next character and also
his weakness that he feels so weak
within his own party that he is doing
what he feels is right by his party it
should be about what's right for the
country that isn't what's happening
right now I just wonder if you think it
also speaks to a deeper problem in
Westminster and like trying to sort of
take the kind of Party politics out of
this um you know Sky News has a podcast
where two of our reporters have been
looking into allegations of bullying the
Open Secret podcast and they found
examples across all parties one staff
are telling them I'm sure every staff
from Parliament has got some a story
even if they weren't bullied they know
someone who was I mean is there a
problem with bullying and the treatment
of Staff in Westminster I think you get
uh you know real problems where you have
an imbalance of power and where people
don't feel able to make complain a map
for too long has been the case in
Westminster and you know we do have a
process now and I hope that people will
come forward where they have been on the
end of poor treatment in the workplace
because no matter where you work you
should be treated with respect and you
shouldn't be subjected to bullying and
the same is true of course right across
government as well and sometimes people
don't feel comfortable coming forward
they want to try and just plow on and do
their best but no one should feel under
that kind of pressure and I think you do
see what happens when you have a more
open culture where people do feel that
they can come forward and you know we've
got more work to do in Westminster
absolutely but I think it does come down
to that that Dynamic around the
imbalance of power and you know we all
of us as politicians have a
responsibility to make sure that you
know we are respectful of others you
know politics can involve you know
robust exchange that's as it should be
but you don't cross that line thank you
very much for being on the program thank
you
Richard Phillips in there from labor now
a little later we're going to be talking
to the former concept of Chancellor Ken
Clark looking forward to that one but
just first we can get the first take
from our Deputy political editor Sam
code Sam there's been an awful lot of
pitch rolling a lot of talking about
difficult decisions is it all going to
be Doom and Gloom tomorrow do you think
you're right Sophie for weeks there's
been absolutely clear Doom and Gloom uh
from the Chancellor from the Prime
Minister we're expecting somewhere in
the order of 20 billion pounds a bit
more of tax Rises 30 billion pounds of
spending cuts and this is all tough
stuff income tax Rises council tax Rises
public spending reductions way to the
second half of this uh decade so the
question really is if they're going to
suck up that pain what's the glue what's
the good news to bind this all together
two things I understand tonight first of
all British cynac has made schools a
priority I understand that actually he's
gonna put his money where his mouth is
there's gonna be some protection for the
school's budgets and the years to come
tomorrow and secondly energy bills now
Jeremy had been expected to abandon to
junk the Liz trust plan to protect
people from those spiraling bills he's
actually going to keep a version of Liz
truss's plan at a less generous level it
has to be said but nevertheless that's
quite a big U-turn for him to suck up
this might be Jeremy Hunt's budget it's
Rishi cnx big moment however it'll be
him that this is all judged from a
really interesting so schools and energy
two things to look out for uh tomorrow
at thank you Sam and now Asam was saying
the chancellor says he's going to be
making quite wateringly difficult
decisions tomorrow on our Sunday program
he told me that everyone is going to be
paying a bit more tax we can talk now to
someone who might know a little more
than most of what is going through at
the Chancellor's mind as he prepares for
the Autumn statement the former
Chancellor Ken Clark thank you so much
for being on the program uh today
pleasure though I'm very out of date
Chancellor I'm not changed since I have
a chance of us Checker yes certainly but
what do you think Jeremy Huntsman is
feeling them
well I think he's been feeling he's
getting caught on a dead terrorism and a
terrible task really really difficult
problems but he's not the first
Chancellor of taking over you know the
consequences of her of a financial
crisis or facing a recession and all the
rest of it but no he's something I bet
he rethinks he's not taken on an Ideal
easy time so uh he's got to get it right
tomorrow and getting it right doesn't
mean getting good write-ups from the
newspapers the day afterwards he will be
judged by whether in a couple of years
time it appears to have worked the only
hope for the government is that in a
couple of years time after we go through
a very hard winter very hard for some
people if the economy then seems to be
picking up and we're coming out of
troubles and so on but tomorrow he's got
to do necessary tough difficult things
which is what half of government's about
all the time anyway and uh ignore the
fact that it'll be hated by large bands
of the public uh just get on and do it
and so you can turn around in two years
time say I told you so we had to do it
it feels like the conservative party is
slightly split to camps you know the
camp that thing looks at least my boys
yes one Camp thinking that um difficult
decisions have to be made the markets
have to be satisfied spending carts tax
Rises the other comes saying hang on a
minute it looks like we're already in a
recession that's probably the worst
thing that you could do right now
where do you fall well he does have to
uh raise taxes and cut public spending I
mean in bold terms uh and uh it is going
to be unpopular and there's a section of
the conservative party that will go ape
because it'll get a bad write-up uh
probably uh in this press and most most
of their constituents realizing we're in
a recession uh and they're going to be
worse off living standards the majority
of people are going to fall over the
next year or two uh I didn't I'm not
sure the banker right that there's only
going to be a shall a resistance I'm not
careful and they'll just want to say
well my constituents want the government
to give them some more money and spend
some more money on the Public Services
they like and cut their taxes you know
they're pretty hard up that's childlike
uh he's going to make the case they have
tried to make the case already I do
think Rishi and his Chancellor Jeremy
have gone around and been preparing the
ground they've been quite open that it's
going to be tough now of course there's
no getting away from the fact when it
comes up with the reality uh there'll be
House of rage and he he can't be
non-political cool he's got to discuss
it extremely carefully how they're going
to get it through the House of Commons
but there are some pretty wild
right-wing people and populist people in
the House of Commons at the moment most
of them are not quite so mad as to drive
the government into an election at the
moment which would cost a very high and
large number of their seats they brought
the government down which opposing a
budget usually does interesting you
mentioned they're an election you know
some people will be looking at the
economic situation which is obviously in
a bad place and thinking the
conservatives have had 12 years in power
surely it's time for a change
well they can't escape the fact we've
had 12 years in power but we started in
an impossible situation everybody
nowadays Mrs George Osborne and says so
he made a mistake with austerity and so
on we took over after the most appalling
financial crash and crisis the economy
was about collapse uh and we we got us
through that what we never did was get
us really back to the Healthy Growth
with low inflation which we'd enjoyed in
in the 90s when we first took the
benefit of Margaret's reforms and we had
the great normality of the 1990s when
again we we had crashes in I took over
after black Wednesday but the the we we
got through to growth with low inflation
and and I I think that we did a good job
at first we kept austerity going for too
long
and then we've been hit by all these
Hammer blows it's a global problem uh
but somebody brexit which is
self-inflicted which is why we're doing
worse than any other G7 country because
we inflicted on ourselves it's a huge
blow to our own trade but we did have
the pandemic and we have the effects of
the war in Ukraine and you'll
acknowledge
Liz truss a government also put the tin
lid on things a rather comic episode
uh when it lives in quality
unfortunately came up with this
childishly simplistic stuff which was
terribly popular you know the daily
mail's headline was at last a real Tory
budget and what was that it was cutting
taxes for the older better off middle
classes and cutting the value of
benefits for the poor although you did
say back in August during the leadership
that both Liz trust and Richie sunak
were offering uh pursuing the votes of
the older prosperous middle class
population and so they were all guilty
of trying to cheer up better off
pensioners well Rishi in the course of
that ludicrous contest when we inflicted
on ourselves and on the country
four weeks of really nauseating sort of
stupid hustings all over the country
with the media demanding they came up
with a new policy off the cuff every day
Richie did say some Sydney things
himself he was drawn into them he did
warn about the basic disaster of doing
what Liz and quasi promptly did but if
you remember he slipped into giving all
sorts of promises which I think he now
says he's reviewing them all yes he is
and he won't actually Implement any of
them until the economic circumstances
allow but he oh he was promising income
tax cuts next year and you know putting
up and all kinds of things as well so I
think my comment then was justified it
was the time when I've never known
British politics reduced to such
ludicrous low-level knock about nonsense
as it was during the campaign with
rishi's warning about fiscal
responsibility being the one redeeming
virtue he had made me support him you
know quite firmly now the chancellor
traditionally allowed to consume alcohol
we're making a fiscal statement yes I
think we've got a great uh photo I was
the last one that did this is you I
think you were drinking whiskey were you
at that point I always had whiskey yes
uh Glenn Faulkner's I think it was
blended whiskey because I visited The
Distillery so I always got my PPS to lay
on a very stiff glass of whiskey I don't
think she really knew the strength of
whiskey so I had a pretty good one and I
recommend it to James I mean I had some
tough budgets my first budget I raised
the tax burden on the country by a
bigger percentage and any Chancellor
since the war but so I did a little bit
of a little political presentation and
flourish the whiskey and add literally
add little or they lived a little around
the serious bits of my speech and all
the rest of it and I don't think people
noticed that I was raising the tax
burden quite as I was but every
Chancellor since Gladstone I think had
done that and I was succeeded by a
Scotsman who stopped it and Gordon
wouldn't have the whiskey and so these
long-standing tradition I mean it was
the only speech of the year that any
member could take alcohol into the
chamber it was the chancellor delivering
a budget a child Gladstone took it in
order to keep himself going for an hour
or a few hours whilst he went ad-libbing
through his great long budget uh I I did
it aside quite like drinking a sip of
whiskey anyway it gives you a bit more
enthusiasm and uh I I did it again I did
deliberately he may use it a little
theatrically and then it was canceled
and no one's had the nerve to take it up
again so Jeremy's a very steady sober
sort of fellow but you never know he
might revive it tomorrow I hope that
that speaker wouldn't stop him if he did
I love that fingers crossed hey fingers
crossed thank you so much it's been a
real pleasure talking to you this
evening thank you pleasure you're
watching at the take we are live in
Westminster up next we'll be talking to
our viewers panel
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back live to Westminster you are
watching the take time now to make uh
find out what our viewers panel make of
what is going to happen tomorrow it's
always good to try and get a bit of a
sense of how people are feeling what
they'd like the government to focus on
uh we can talk to Hannah at first Hannah
Walker a labor voter from uh Dorset
thanks for being on the program Hannah
Hannah what are you hoping to see
tomorrow
well I I think one of the things that
bothers me is that the previous PM
effectively took out a credit card in
our name without our permission and
wrapped up 40 billion quids worth of
debt on it at very high interest rates
um and and nobody gave her permission to
do that that was public money to be used
for public services and
um nobody had a right just back it away
in their Reckless gamble so when when
grave faced ministers tell us that they
have to make very difficult decisions
and eye-watering cuts
um what they're really telling us is
that we have to pay a second time
for the money we've already paid
essentially to get um half the amount of
services and just changing the front man
doesn't make any difference at all to
the fact that we are significantly worse
off and one of the reasons for this
large black hole is because a PM only a
few weeks ago
threw away a lot of our public money
that we have paid certainly like the as
you say you know the strong feelings of
people about what happened uh previously
under their last conservative
Administration let's bring in Andy flang
now shall we from uh Suffolk and are you
a social worker I think how uh what
would you like to see tomorrow I am
foreign
I just kind of see how the we keep on
having these uh bust and boom it's a bit
like a kind of poor Star Trek really
where spatial anomalies open up as a
debt crisis and then appear to close
magically and there's no strategic
planning and right at the moment the
poorest are going to suffer the most
they're the ones who are actually going
to be not being able to kind of put the
heating on if you're living in really
poor
accommodation we've seen a really tragic
case recently of the child who died from
um the spores in their home and so you
really got to wonder what we'll be doing
because also if you don't actually look
after the most vulnerable they will go
on to the NHS waiting list and that is a
concern so what you say you spend later
really uh glad you spoke about the case
of that poor little boy it's a really
shocking story this week right let's
talk to a pradeep now shall we pradeep
zakataran who is talking to us from
Cumbria are there any uh particular
areas that you'd like to see protected
I certainly want to see um their health
and defense
um uh kind of departments not getting
Cuts I think with the current climate we
need the money in those departments and
I also
um I want to see transparent clear a
speech from the chancellor no jargon
North child taxes no ability to change
our council tax
um taxes through referendums or so forth
and I want to see how growth is possible
we're all talking about
tax Rises and cuts how do you grow the
economy how do you Empower small and
medium-term businesses to grow and how
do you actually tax windfall tax the
larger corporations so clear data and
evidence-based kind of points will be
good
right let's bring in Rob now shall we
rob Tyler uh talking to us from Bolton
conservative voter Rob what are you
hoping to see tomorrow
Rob can you hear me okay Rob
I'm not sure Rob can hear us
unfortunately okay let's go to Tim in
box at six instead I'm just repeating
what I'm hearing my year book six means
nothing to you guys let's talk to Tim
who's talking to us uh from uh Dorset
Tim what do you want to see tomorrow
um I want to see a decent budget but I
really don't know what's going to happen
but what we've seen and witnessed over
over recent years or a number of
conservative administrations which have
founded and part of the reason they've
landed is because they've been populated
with ideologically driven individuals
who've just got no empathy they don't
care about people pretty Patel and her
bulloughing
suela bravaman dreaming of seeing
playing loads of people taking off to
Rwanda for an uncertain future we've got
a kanikaze quantine damaging crashing
the economy and now these and Gavin
Williamson in his text messages and now
we've got the allegations being made
against Dominic Rob there is no place in
our government for people like that
right let's bring in uh is our shall we
is our best charging next is our are
there any areas that you're hoping are
protected when it comes suspending cuts
okay Isla can you hear me Sophie uh
just asking what you're hoping to hear
from I think you're breaking Sophie are
we breaking up a bit yeah give us your
thoughts anyway
no we have lost Islam it's going very
well today uh never mind let's try Rob
again Rob can you hear us again Rob no
we're gonna move on we're going to move
on well I think we did get a flavor
certainly from our panel uh this evening
about some of the anxiety I guess around
what is going to be announced uh
tomorrow let's talk to uh Sam shall we
our Deputy uh political uh editor who is
here so we're gonna have no technical
problems speaking to you which is always
a relief uh Sam what are we expecting
so we have heard for weeks about how
gloomy it is how bad the situation how
much heavy lifting tax cuts and spending
uh connect Rises and spending cuts are
going to have to do uh when Jeremy Hunt
stands up uh we think it's about 11 30
12 o'clock tomorrow in the House of
Commons that he'll deliver uh his first
Autumn statement uh he is of course the
fourth Chancellor this year it's living
the third big economic statement so
we're hardly unfamiliar with the ritual
uh that we'll see
um but it's going to be difficult
because effectively the path that this
man and Rishi sunak the prime minister
is going to take us on is completely
different from the one two weeks uh two
months ago pioneered by Liz trust now
she was all about whatever she said she
was all about more borrowing to do more
spending and these two want to put us on
a very different uh path and and in
effect I think tomorrow will be a bit
like the sort of memorial service for
trossonomics but the question is can you
get all the Tory MPS singing from the
same hint sheet giving that all the
things that they said that they leaved
over the summer lower taxis and the like
all that's going to be junked in favor
of essentially a Prudence trying to fill
what these guys say is a 55 billion
pound black hole
what's interesting Sophie to me is that
essentially just a month ago we got rid
of a prime minister Liz trust because
everybody thought she went too far with
her additional borrowing and and really
the conversation amongst some Tory MPS
is not as many as with trust is whether
or not Rishi seen that can join me are
about to make the same mistake they're
going to go too far but in the other
direction too much uh spending cuts too
many tax Rises is it palatable for the
public is it palatable for the Tory
party really interesting to see at the
conservative party of course so fraction
we've got a bit of a sense about that
with Ken Clark I think as well
um
I got to ask the question I asked you
this question uh on Sunday I've got to
ask it again
um do you think that all of this pain is
going to happen Mel stride saying some
of these Cuts aren't going to be into he
doesn't have to balance the books till
2027 2028 he said well Mel Strider
effectively agreed with the banana
analysis that if the all of this happens
I'm a banana he made it clear that a lot
of the pain was later in the parliament
perhaps after an election after you've
had to promise something else the job of
Tomorrow is convincing the markets that
you're serious providing the plan is
robust enough who cares what happens in
2026 2027. a really interesting to talk
as always uh some coats there you are
watching at the take we are live in
Westminster on a big evening because up
next we're going to be focusing on the
situation in Ukraine we're going to be
speaking to the former National Security
advisor Lord Ricketts
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Johnston a Sky News correspondent part
of the teams based here in the Midland
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain World
we're getting more and more stabbings
and essentially I think it's more and
more younger children there's a team
we're not really surprised by anything
these days
so it's reports of a male who can start
repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here at are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
[Music]
the river 7 is still rising and people
here in Ironbridge have been told it
could go up by another meter before it
starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process of
putting it back together we aim to be
the best and most trusted place for news
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take well we can turn now
to the other really significant story of
the day and NATO says that it thinks a
missile that landed in Poland killing
two people is likely to be from
Ukrainian air defenses now that view has
been disputed by Ukraine but following a
huge barrage of attacks across Ukraine
it of course has further rushed it up
the tensions between the west and Russia
with talk of invoking article 4 of the
NATO treaty well we can speak now to
Lord Peter Ricketts the former National
Security advisor and foreign office at
permanent secretary thank you so much
for being with us
um NATO say the missile is likely
Ukrainian Ukraine are disputing that
what is your sense
well I think the most important point is
that this incident only happened because
Ukraine had been under this massive
bombardment by the Russians against
their civilian infrastructure
um so that I think is the most important
thing that was happening yesterday
um whoever fired this missile it was
only because of that if it was a
Ukrainian in missile which looks more
and more likely it was because they were
firing in self-defense against this
incoming barrage of Russell missiles so
I'm sure the experts will tell us pretty
quickly when we are there whose missile
it was but the bigger background is that
this is one of the dangers one of the
things that happens when Russia behaves
like this going to war with the
neighboring countries
of course Poland is a member of NATO is
this the kind of thing that could
trigger a NATO response
it's worth just remembering what article
4 and article fiber about Article 4 of
the NATO treaty is consultations that's
effectively what's been happening today
the NATO Council met they pulled
information they expressed solidarity
with Poland and they said they're
keeping close touch with events Article
5 I mean if a member State Fields is
under an armed attack and that's the
Criterion an armed attack then NATO
members have agreed to act collectively
but the NATO treaty it's a political
treaty it's not a legal commitment and
each nation is free to decide what kind
of support it can give so it doesn't put
you on an escalator to you know
inevitable military conflict but it is a
collective defense vehicle now if this
was an errant Russian missile that went
Australian hit Poland that's hardly a
deliberate armed attack on Poland it
would be a very different thing if the
Russians made a deliberate attack on a
Polish military installation then we
really would be into issue of how NATO
would respond on Military
it's interesting isn't it do you feel
that because of you know the alliance
and the consequences that could have
that Russia is I guess holding back
slightly when it comes to other
countries other than Ukraine
yes definitely I mean I think Putin you
know he's megalomaniac about Ukraine but
he understands the power of NATO and
this power of deterrence that if he does
deliberately attack a NATO State there
will be an armed response from NATO I
think there's no doubt about that and
he's got no doubt about that Ukraine of
course is not a member state of NATO
it's a close partner it's being
supported by NATO but it doesn't benefit
yet from that Collective guarantee which
effectively says you attack a member of
NATO and NATO will come back at you very
hard that has worked so far that red
line has been respected by the Russians
assuming that this was not a deliberate
attack by Russia on Poland which I
really don't think it was
I was reflecting a bit earlier today
about you know the war in Ukraine about
all the appalling images that we've seen
about all the discussions you know that
we've had and the international
discussions as well
and just thinking how I just cannot
really see a way out of it frankly right
now
is there any path that you can see for
an end of the war
I mean I think you're right
um I hear talk about people saying
there's got to be a negotiated solution
you know we've got to be a peace
settlement here I mean I don't think
that after all they've been through the
ukrainians are about to do a deal with
Russia which leaves Russia in possession
of some of their territory nor do I
think Putin is about to do a complete
unconditional withdrawal for all his
groups so I'm afraid what this is going
to head up to is a stalemate over the
winter where more or less in the
position the forces are now and then
probably more fighting next year I guess
in the end some sort of armistice or
truce a bit like we've had in Korea for
the last 70 years where there is a line
of Separation which is
um overseen by International
peacekeeping forces but neither side
have accepted that they've won or lost
them there is no durable piece that's
the most likely I can see from this it's
not a good one for Europe or for Ukraine
but it's certainly better of the Ukraine
you know than if the Russians had
succeeded in their original objective
what analysis uh to hear but I do you
know accept the kind of I guess accuracy
of what you you're saying Lord Ricketts
always yeah good talk
thank you very much for being on the
program
oh well that is it for the take uh we'll
be back next week every week of course
on Wednesday at 9 00 PM you can also
join us at Sky News for all of our state
coverage of the Autumn statement uh
tomorrow I'll be guiding you uh through
that from the morning so I do hope you
tune in for that next up it's Sky News
at 10.
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign